MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
again to 8.701.
So this is the fifth
section of our introduction.
I'd like to talk about the early
history and the people involved
in nuclear and particle physics.
I cover the period from
1820 to the beginning
of the Second World War.
other elements of the later
history of the development
of the standard model--
parity violation, CP violation--
those aspects will
be covered when
we talk about the
actual physics involved.
But I'd like to give you
some more background.
Especially since we start
the discussion with particle
physics, it's good
to understand what
was the starting ground,
which shoulders did
people stand on at the time.
Important to realize
here, at this point,
I'm not an historian.
I like to read about history.
I just finished an
interesting book on Einstein.
I like to have a good
understanding how
the people of the time, the
time itself, and the physics
discovery interacted.
It helps me in understanding
the process of being scientific.
When you look at
history, you find
a lot of places
where progress was
made by curiosity and by
doing things which are not
the common way to proceed.
And so one learns this
by looking at history.
And I might give you a number
of examples here as well.
So diving in one of the
questions at the time,
going back, again, almost 200
years is how old was the Earth?
How old is the Earth?
And about 200 years ago, people
started to argue whether or not
the 10,000 of years,
which was long
thought to be the age of the
Earth, are actually correct.
And specifically geologists
and biologists argued that this
cannot be true.
They observed how slowly
geological and biological
processes such as erosion
and evolution occur.
And if you just try
to, by observation, put
all of those ducks in
a row, if you want,
you find that the Earth
must be much, much older
than those 10,000 years.
On the contrary, some physicists
argued that the Earth cannot be
as old as several hundreds of
millions of years because it
would be, by now, a very
cold and dark place.
One of the opposers of
evolution was Lord Kelvin,
or William Thompson.
And he argued with classical
thermodynamics calculations
that the Earth cannot be as
old as those 300 million years
as Darwin writes in initial
printing of The Origin
of Species.
Herman Helmholtz,
a few years later,
tried to use energy compensation
principles to calculate
how much heat from the sun would
radiate if the energy comes
from slow contraction.
And he, by converting
gravitational potential energy
to heat, calculated age cannot
be more than 18 million years.
So putting those together,
you find, on the one side,
the physicists,
theology might be
a different dimension
to this discussion,
and then geologists
and biologists.
And a complicated question.
I mean, really there was
something to be learned.
Something was not
quite understood.
And so we come back
to this question.
Next slide.
But then progress was made in
the understanding of physics.
And here to be named are
Henri Becquerel, for example,
for the discovery of
radiation from uranium
and Ernest Rutherford
for the discovery,
by studying this
radiation, that there
must be at least two different
sources of radiation.
And he called them, simply by
following the Greek alphabet,
alpha and beta rays.
In the same year, J.
J. Thompson discovered
a particle, the electron charged
particle, or the electron.
Becquerel's story is
quite interesting,
as he was trying to understand
the material Roentgen studied.
And he was interested
in figuring out what
fluorescence material can do.
And again, this is one of the
examples where he, by accident,
discovered that it is
actually not the fact
that you have a material,
you expose this to sunlight,
you wait a little while, and
it still radiates the light.
So this has delayed the
fluorescence of the material.
It is not quite the full story
to some fluorescent materials.
So he discovered
this by accident,
by putting the mineral
in a drawer, together
with a photo plate,
and found that there
was only a very short, limited
evidence from that photo plate
to be radiated by the sun.
But it was basically foggy
from being in the same drawer
as a mineral.
But this was a rather
accidental discovery.
Marie and Pierre Curie proposed
the new term, radioactivity,
for materials which
generally emit light.
And they discovered
additional materials
to the uranium which was
discovered by Becquerel.
So they discovered
thorium, for example,
and later also the elements
of polonium and radium.
And they discovered
that those elements
radiate a lot of radioactivity.
So Marie Curie was able to
measure the energy being
radiated, and found
that a gram of radium
can emit up to 140
calories per hour.
And so you find that
a gram of radium
is able to power, basically,
the energy you need in order
to survive--
provide the energy.
So moving a little
forward, so then uranium
specifically, but other
radioactive materials,
were studied.
And Paul Villard
discovered that there
must be a third component
of radiation which behaves
different from the other two.
And he called these
gamma rays, again,
simply following the
alphabet and moving along
to the third letter.
Rutherford then connects
these findings first
to the question of
the age of the Earth.
And he simply suggests that
it's those radioactive elements
which are in ores in the core
of the Earth which provide
additional source
of feed sufficient,
because of the
connectivity of the Earth,
to keep the Earth
geologically active.
And he comes to the
conclusion that the Earth
might be as well a
few billion years old,
as we know now it is.
So putting this in context,
at the very same time
in Bern, Switzerland, a
clerk named Albert Einstein
has a fantastic year.
He, in one year, comes
up with a sequence
of theoretical discoveries.
One is special relativity.
And he uses the findings
of special relativity
to derive that there's an
equivalence between energy
and mass.
And this equivalence,
as we will see later,
when we discussed nuclear
physics specifically,
is very important to understand
nuclear decay, nuclear fission,
and nuclear fusion,
and figuring out why,
if you have a
component state that
seems to be lighter than the
sum of the individual components
making up this particle.
Rutherford was a pioneer
with collider experiments
in the sense that he used
other particles a lot
to bombard all
kinds of materials.
So what he found first is
that, if alpha particles,
when stopped, turn into helium.
So the alpha
particle itself grabs
on to the electrons from
the material it collides in.
There was a technical problem.
I'll just continue.
And that turns into helium.
His students,
Marsden and Geiger,
then perform a very famous
gold foil experiment.
So you all probably
have heard about this,
taking an alpha particle
source and you shine it
on a foil of gold.
And then you look at the angular
distribution of the particles,
which go through
or which have been
backscattered from this foil.
And Rutherford then
takes those measurements
and turns them into a
solar-system-like model
of atoms which are
essentially made out
of empty space and a very
small, intense nuclei.
So Rutherford then continues
with this experiment
and it's able to produce,
by bombarding nitrogen
with other particles,
protons and oxygen.
And this is, in fact, the
first human-engineered nuclear
reaction.
So now we are in the year 1919,
just after the First World
War ended.
On the theoretical
side, this is the time
that quantum mechanics
is developed.
And Dirac then
combines relativity
with quantum
mechanics, which then
leads to the so-called
Dirac equation, which
we're going to look at very
shortly in this class as well.
This equation is
quite interesting
because it predicts the
existence of negative energy
states.
And so then that just
comes out of the equations.
And then you ask yourself,
what's happening here?
You can have an interpretation
that, for an electron,
of the electron which
traveled backwards in time,
or you interpret
them as electrons
with negative energies.
And so this then leads to
the prediction of antimatter.
Pauli and Fermi, they're
puzzled by a problem
of energy conservation
in the second case.
And so this is something
which is rather weird
and is a big challenge to
the physics of the time.
And they've solved
this challenge
by proposing a new particle
which is rather light
and doesn't interact
with the detectors they
had available at the time.
So it just escapes undetected.
They call this
particle the neutrino.
A year later,
neutrons are directly
detected in
experiments by Chadwick
with beryllium and
other particles again.
And then the predicted
anti-electrons, the positrons,
were discovered by Anderson in
tracts of photographic plates
which looked like
electrons but they
curve in the wrong direction.
So either they have
the opposite charge
or they travel
backwards in time.
They didn't have quite the
time resolution to [INAUDIBLE]..
All right, also on
the theoretical side,
it needed to be understood how
neutrons and protons actually
bind together in nuclei.
And so Hideki Yukawa proposes
the existence of a strong force
which is really, really
strong and binds those nuclear
together to a degree that you
cannot easily break them apart.
And then Bethe calculates how
nuclear fusion, rather than
the fission process, can be
used in order to power the sun.
So for this, he proposes
a three-step process,
the so-called
proton-proton chain,
which I will not discuss
here but we will certainly
discuss later in this class.
And then there's
more developments
in the area of nuclear physics.
And this progress
is made by, again,
using all kinds of materials
and bombarding with each other.
So for example, by colliding
neutrons with uranium,
one discovers a process
of nuclear fission.
This was done by Lise
Meitner and Otto Hahn
in the late 1930s.
So from there on, there's
interesting further
developments going
on in the sense
that many physicists
at the time in Europe
are rather concerned
by the developments
of the Nazi Party in Germany.
In the '40s already after the
start of the Second World War,
Albert Einstein wrote a letter
to Theodore Roosevelt pointing
out that there is a real
threat that the Nazis are
going to develop a bomb
based on nuclear processes.
And so this then led to
the Manhattan Program
in the US and the development of
the first nuclear bombs or atom
bombs.
And in August 1945,
the first two bombs
were dropped on
Japan, which led then
to the surrender of
the Japanese empire
and the end of the
Second World War.
With that, I stop the discussion
of those early developments.
I hope you got a
first glimpse and use
this as a starting
point to read further.
Those characters, Lise
Meitner, for example--
I'm looking at her
picture right now--
very, very interesting to
see how those people were
connected, how those
people communicated,
and in which environment
they had to work.
Lise Meitner, for
example, was Jewish.
And she left Europe, had to
flee from the Nazis in the '30s,
while making these
kind of discoveries.
Also interesting is maybe
the historical introduction
to elementary particles.
I have this here in
David Griffiths' book.
This starts with this
kind of classical era
and then goes beyond
the Second World War
and introduces the findings in
particle physics beyond what I
explained to this point.
So I hope you enjoyed this.
This is basically the last of
these introductory lectures
which doesn't come
with a set of problems,
with a set of things you
should be interacting with.
So the next one will
already do that.
And we will use
this in the Thursday
recitation of the first
week to have discussion.